polluer la planète en se logeant une
idée qui a priori n'a rien d'évident
pour la plupart d'entre nous et pourtant
tous les jours nous polluons sens à voir
avec nos habitations
pour nous rendre compte de l'impact de
nos logements il suffit de prendre un
peu de hauteur
nous embarquons dans cet hélicoptère
très spécial à bord un ingénieur
spécialiste des déperditions d'énergie
lui seul peut voir nos maisons comme
jamais nous nous les voyons
il survole les toits du village et à
l'aide d'une caméra thermique ils
repèrent toutes les pertes de chaleur
des habitations qui s'affiche sur cet
écran
normalement tous les toits devrait être
en bleu signe qui concerne la chaleur
dans la maison mais ici des tâches
apparaissent violette jaune et même
rouge par endroits
[Musique]
de la chaleur qui s'échappe par la
toiture un gâchis de chauffage
incroyable car c'est le cas de la
plupart des maisons de ce village
nos toitures peuvent perdre jusqu'à 30 %
de l'énergie que nous consommons
et il n'y a pas que le toit qu'il est
sûre la chaleur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parfois les pertes d'énergie se situent
dans des endroits inimaginable
pour mieux comprendre nous nous rendons
dans cette maison rien qu'à la couleur
de son toit on voit déjà que les
propriétaires gaspiller l'énergie
et à l'intérieur d'autres surprises nous
attendent
c'est un pavillon construit au début des
années 90 le domicile de pascal
stéphanie et leurs deux enfants
comme la plupart des pavillons de cette
époque ils sont chauffés avec ce genre
de radiateur isolé dans un coin de la
pièce et pas très performant
on les allume beaucoup ils chauffent pas
beaucoup tout cas elle ressentit fn long
terme de température pour avoir moins
froid pascal est obligé d'utiliser sa
cheminée en permanence
alors pour arrêter de gaspiller de
l'énergie la famille a fait appel à un
spécialiste des fuites de chaleur
au petit matin pascal et l'expert font
le tour de la maison pour détecter
toutes les pertes d'énergie armé d'une
caméra infrarouge
première surprise côté jardin le maillon
faible n'est pas la porte fenêtre mais
le sol
[Musique]
sous la fenêtre vous avez une bande
orange l'a donc plus chaudes c'est à
dire c'est de la chaleur qui s'évacue 20
de l'intérieur vers l'extérieur la
problématique c'est en fait c'est la
dalle qui est le seuil de la porte en
fait la porte fenêtre la chaleur et
trans aux sous la porte par nadal le
problème ce n'est pas le bord de fenêtre
comme souvent mais bien une mauvaise
isolation du sol de la salle à manger et
pascal n'est pas au bout de ses
découverts
à l'intérieur au niveau des fenêtres ce
sont les montants qui laisse rentrer le
froid
est là il ya un problème de jeu
mais pour pascal la pire révélation
l'attend dans la chambre de son fils
l'expert va déceler une entrée d'air
froid qui passe à travers le mur malgré
son épaisseur est apparemment un défaut
de construction c'est à dire là le mur
on voit uniforme et quand on regarde
avec la caméra thermique ici c'est bien
dans les rouges juste à côté il ya un
point froid à 13 degrés quand même
conséquence la chambre est refroidi de 4
degrés malgré des radiateurs qui tourne
à plein régime avec toutes ces pertes
c'est comme si pascal laisser une
fenêtre grande ouverte en permanence sa
maison est donc ce qu'on appelle une
passoire énergétique
bientôt à bientôt pour la chauffer il
faut donc beaucoup plus d'énergie
[Musique]
et c'est cette énergie gaspillée qui
génère davantage de pollution
en france cette habitation sur dix sont
considérés comme des passoires à énergie
à cause de toutes ces fuites elle
consomme 3 à 5 fois plus que nécessaire
pour se chauffer
résultat trois tonnes de co2 par an
voilà ce que génère en moyenne une
habitation rien qu'avec le chauffage
à l'échelle de la planète nos logements
sont donc responsables d'un quart des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre comme
le co2
or en s'accumulant segas forment une
sorte de couvercle qui empêche la
chaleur du soleil de se dissiper les
réchauffe ainsi la température ambiante
c'est ce qu'on appelle le réchauffement
climatique
et cela provoquerait tous les règlements
que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
comme les sécheresses
ou la fonte de la banquise
alors comment réduire cette facture qui
pèse autant sur la planète que ce notre
porte monnaie
[Musique]
nous sommes allés voir une experte en
bâtiment écologique
cet architecte qui enseigne à travers le
monde a réalisé des centaines de
logements elle sait exactement comment
nous pourrions réduire notre impact
écologique avec une solution à la portée
de chacun d'entre nous habiter à un
impact extrêmement important positif
bien souvent négatifs m
aujourd'hui c'est essentiellement le
chauffage parce qu'on a des maisons très
très isolée donc la solution c'est quoi
alors la première chose à faire c'est
isoler sa maison donc ça veut dire
l'enveloppé d'un matériau bien nous
voulons avoir des fenêtres qu'il soit
bien étanche ça c'est la première action
la deuxième action on la connaît ces
échanges et 122 chauffage et avoir des
équipements qu'ils soient efficaces la
première chose à faire pour polluer et
dépenser moins ce n'est donc pas de
changer son mode de chauffage comme on
le croit souvent mais d'abord de bien
isoler sa maison un grand pas pour la
planète qui n'est qu'un tout petit geste
pour l'homme